[Music]
we just heard that joe biden's mandating
vaccines for 80 million private sector
workers larry elders running for
governor in california the recall
election there is on september 14th
he joins us with his reaction larry i
don't care what you think of vaccines
you're for them you're against them
america got a little less free today and
there's nothing we're going to be able
to do to change that
well you're right and i'm not
anti-vaccine i've been vaccinated i
think vaccines do work i'm in a
high-risk category but a lot of people
have made a very different decision and
you're quite right freedom ought to
stand for something this is on a
collision course to the united states
supreme court
and i believe that what joe biden just
now did will be ruled to be
unconstitutional take a while for it to
get there but i think maybe five four
maybe even six three it's going to be
determined to be unconstitutional jesse
the problem is people in california
larry they love it
they don't care if it's legal they just
want to jam this stuff down people's
throats into their arms they don't care
about whether it's right or wrong
they just go along with whatever the
government tells them
well i'm not sure how much longer that's
going to last a whole lot of people are
ticked off that's why two million people
signed their petition jesse a good uh a
third of them were the very people
independents and democrats who voted for
him just two years earlier a whole lot
of people are upset about this my
opponent gavin newsom has mandated that
if you're a state worker and you've not
been vaccinated you're going to be
tested once a week and you're going to
be required to wear a face mask at work
a lot of people are hopping mad about
that nurses are mad about it cops are
mad about it firefighters are mad about
it there's going to be a lawsuit as i
said this is going to be on a collision
course up to the united states supreme
court and ultimately the people who want
freedom are going to be vindicated
and that governor there has failed to
manage that state whether it's the water
whether it's the energy whether it's the
forests
whether it's the pandemic he has failed
to manage that state and that's really
what this entire election is about or
should be about but larry they don't
want it to be about that they want it to
be about personal attacks you were
attacked broad daylight yesterday in la
here's that clip watch
[Music]
so you see the white lady in the gorilla
mask throwing eggs what exactly happened
there larry
well you know she might be one of the 20
000 people that were released early
from our prisons felons many of whom
were violent offenders under this
governor
i don't know we have too soft on crime
d.a's i consider this to be one of the
many intersections in california the
intersection between lawlessness and
homelessness i was at a homeless
encampment in venice and a lot of people
are angry homeowners are angry families
are angry children have to go and pass
these people to and from school and the
homeless population is in danger and
it's also a health hazard and nothing's
being done about it that's one of the
many failures of this governor so it was
a very angry ugly scene you know if i
were a democrat obviously this would be
called systemic racism they'd be calling
it a hate crime i don't like to play
that game i knew doing all this there
was a big article about me a negative in
the new york times never once mentioned
that i'm black never wanted to mention
that i would be the first black governor
of california i never made a big deal
out about that i don't want people to
vote for me or against me because i'm
black but on the very same page of the
new york times there's a big article
about the quote first female governor of
new york close quote even though she
didn't get elected she was basically
appointed because the other governor
resigned so they cared about the first
when it was a female democrat but
couldn't give a rip about the first when
it was a black republican i'll say it
looks like a hate crime to me gorilla
mask
first potential black governor the
largest state in the country
i we we reached out to newsome's office
to maxine waters office to kamala harris
asking them to condemn
no response
how does that make you feel crickets
yeah
crickets and uh and when gavin newsom's
children were criticized because gavin
newsom mandated that you wear face masks
outdoors and his kids were at summer
camp not wearing face masks we put out a
statement saying leave gavin newsom's
children out of this but the governor
has not put out a statement about this
white woman apparently a white woman
wearing a gorilla mask threw an egg at
me i don't expect that because look all
these people have come in
joe biden has made a statement bernie
sanders has made a statement uh barack
obama's cut a commercial and nobody has
uttered the following words jesse gavin
newsom has done a good job for the
people of california you won't hear that
because he has it not on crime not on
homelessness not on the decline in the
quality of public education a a former
state senator leader of the of the state
senate at the time her name is gloria
romero she's still a democrat has
crossed party lines and has endorsed my
candidacy largely because of school
choice a cost that i'm going to champion
so this is across the board it's not
just democrats not just independents
people are fed up which is why people
are leaving california for the first
time in our state's 170 year history
another thing you won't hear about is
this story in the mainstream media can't
find it on cnn washington post won't
cover it just imagine if it had been the
other way stacey abrams
maxine
something like that forget about it but
this is how they rig elections larry you
get the big media colludes with the big
donors to suppress negative stories that
come out of their precincts and then
they hurl negative
smears at you and that's how they rig
elections and that takes away the power
of the people to vote freely and fairly
you just mentioned obama releasing this
video message about you let's listen to
that
hello californians you've got a big
choice to make by september 14th
governor newsome has spent the past year
and a half protecting california
communities now republicans are trying
to recall him from office and overturn
common-sense coveted safety measures for
health care workers and school staff
your vote could be the difference
between protecting our kids and putting
them at risk
bringing in the big guns larry barack
joe biden kamala
netflix ceo reed hastings throwing his
wallet around man they're all in because
if you win
that just shows the
liberal
mechanism that they have super majority
fail
in that state
well that's right and obama called this
the republicans republicans 63 percent
of hispanics voted for gavin newsom two
years earlier now the polls show a
majority of hispanics want him out i
just now mentioned former democrat
senate leader gloria romero has crossed
party lines to support me a majority of
independents
now want him gone and they voted for
gavin newsom two years ago so it's a
nice try i notice obama did not say
governor gavin newsom has done a good
job for the people of california exactly
because you can't defend this man's
record it is indefensible exactly right
all right fresh off the birthday party
in the vineyard barack obama weighing in
on larry larry good luck out there thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else